[Musique]
dans la capitale italienne
manifestation contre la guerre en
ukraine
[Musique]
il se des milliers à dénoncer les
horreurs du conflit mais le coût de
l'énergie est également au coeur des
préoccupations
ma dernière facture de gaz était de 170
euros
mais celle que j'ai reçu ce mois-ci à 2
270 euros c'est 100 euros de plus c'est
un coup de massue pour nous
c'est inquiétant de savoir qu'on ne
dépend pratiquement que d'un seul
fournisseur il faut diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement d'énergie
diversifier l'approvisionnement
énergétique
c'est le souhait du gouvernement italien
mais aussi de toute l'union européenne
la russie est le premier fournisseur de
gaz de l'union et représente 40% de ses
importations
pourtant rome fait déjà appel à d'autres
pays
l'algérie lui faut ni actuellement 25 %
de sa consommation
et il y a les pays du golfe de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée mais les
importations sont soumises aux lois du
marché
le qatar est le plus grand producteur
mondial de gaz naturel liquéfié et ils
vont ce gnl au plus gros importateur le
japon
c'est clair que si l'italie demande
d'augmenter les volumes le qatar peut
demander une contrepartie pour dévier
une partie de son gaz ce sont des
dynamiques commerciales mais tout ceci
se fait dans le cadre d'accords
politiques entre les étals
des 27 états de l'union c'est
l'allemagne qui remporte la palme de la
plus grande dépendance à l'énergie russe
plus de 50% de son gaz et plus de 75% de
son pétrole brut proviennent de russie
dans cette usine du brandebourg on
fabrique des dalles en céramique est
l'unique source d'énergie et le gaz
on consomme chaque année entre 12 et 13
millions de mètres cubes de gaz
ici la totalité du gaz utilisé vient du
russie l'arrêt des importations
porterait donc à coup fatal à la
production pour nous ce serait
évidemment un risque énorme car si
l'allemagne décide de rationner le gaz
ce ne serait certainement pas pour le
donner à la production de carrelage
pour les entreprises et le gouvernement
allemand il faut absolument sortir de
cette dépendance
dans cette région carbonifère en
particulier l'industrie milite pour une
refonte urgente de la stratégie
énergétique allemande
on avait décidé de sortir de l'atome et
du charbon mais on doit reconsidérer ses
décisions et se demander si elle ne met
pas en danger l'économie allemande nos
besoins énergétiques
on peut constater ces jours ci à quel
point nous sommes dépendants
alors l'allemagne va-t-elle ralentir sa
transition énergétique pour gagner en
marge de manoeuvre pas si sûr à berlin
les militants contre l'atome y sont
résolument opposés
c'est absurde complètement absurde
france pourrait justement mettre toute
notre énergie dans le solaire et
les éoliennes et pas nucléaire n'est pas
le cas
[Applaudissements]
et il n'y a pas qu'en allemagne que
c'est problématique se pose
aux pays-bas à groningue se trouve l'un
des plus gros gisement gazier d'europe
mais l'exploitation de ces seules
devaient cesser cette année car elle est
à l'origine de très nombreux
tremblements de terre or manche
[Musique]
et je ne les entends 20 des tremblements
de terre cette porte ne voulait pas
s'ouvrir alors que je voulais sortir
parce que j'entendais les murs se
fissurent et cicor que j'avais
l'impression de la maison entière allait
s'écrouler
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
reina est inquiète car si
l'approvisionnement en gaz russe est
remise en cause la fermeture du site de
grenoble pourrait être reporté
c'est une sorte de compromis que la
société néerlandaise doit faire est ce
qu on augmente la production à groningue
pour moins dépendre de la russie mais en
prenant le risque d'engendrer plus de
tremblements de terre
450 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
sont encore à exploiter ici un gisement
potentiel que pourrait considérer
l'europe dans les mois prochains